tu m'as pas de l'habitat l'état et
l'état va pas ou quoi c'est la merde
je suis avec eux je suis l'heureux je
suis éducateur c'est un petit peu excité
parce qu'on part quinze jours en mer là
par terre mer avec eva mon courage mais
c'est quoi ce traquenard non non je
travaille pour la méditerranée avec ça
mais par trop mal lui ni eux ni moi on a
envie de passer quinze jours ensemble
parce que pendant dix ans j'étais flic
alabak
[Musique]
d'accord ne bouge pas ça serait la
cuisine et du coca ya pas de kwacha mais
on part dans cinq minutes donc si tu
veux tu pourras envolé à l'épicerie au
carrefour mais il nous parle et nous
parle comme à dire c'est pas très grand
mais vous verrez on ne serait pas
dépaysé de la garde à vue on va pas
tomber dans son piège c'est notre à
verser
c'est la merde là mon bateau cepandant
hlm tout ce qui trait de fringues ou
autre ça finit par dessus bord
enfin si tu vas voir des dauphins match
aller au parc jacques wattez
cession n'a pas besoin de vie depuis le
départ il vous sert à rien excusez moi
ils peuvent piquer une tête c'est pas
évident parce que je vous préviens je
m'arrêterai pas si et elle est un petit
peu fort avec les jeunes je suis déjà
très gentil de partir avec vous par
contre me demande pas d'être pote avec
eux
[Musique]
rien c'est quoi cette histoire on vient
de voir l'association ils ont eu ta mère
hystérique
[Musique]
on peut pas participer à une fugue c'est
impossible que tu demanderas lyonnais
vraiment prendre le risque de perdre ton
taf pour une richesse qui a fait huit
emplacements dans l'air un petit peu
sauvage comme ça mais quand vous
apprendre à l'école
je m'en fous magro connecter avec la
nature d'accord c'est des gamins sa fait
mais je fais là non c'était pas lucide
[Musique]
je sais quoi alex je crois que tu as
oublié pourquoi tu fais ce métier
il y avait du coq depuis le début et
sinon on peut pas avoir un peu de biais
ouais je veux une turlute avec
les relations sexuelles sont strictement
interdites à l'intérieur de ce bateau
c'est à dire que c'est moi je dois quel
âge peut pas heureusement moment il
n'est pas sorti de sa bouche comme si tu
aurais pas cuvée les gros même avec un
taser je te dise pas